Brian kohlberger is the man accused of
the student killings that shocked
America he faces murder charges on
multiple counts murder in the first
degree yes
yes yes yes
he answered four times yes to
acknowledge the four murders he's
charged with the prosecuting attorney
but the judge had to plead not guilty on
his behalf after coburger declined to
plead guilty or otherwise
he is accused of entering this house at
King Road and Moscow Idaho and in the
middle of the night carrying out
quadruple murder
the victims were three female flatmates
and a Partners staying the night Ethan
Chapman and Zana kernodle were stabbed
to death in one bedroom
lifelong friends Kelly gonsalves and
Madison Morgan were killed in another
of two students left unharmed in the
house one told detectors she stood
Frozen as a man dressed in black wearing
a mask and with bushy eyebrows walked
past her
police would take six weeks to arrest
the Brian coburger a criminal justice
student at Washington State University
we actually don't have like crosswalks
oh this was him a few weeks before the
murders a police officer stopped him for
a traffic offense in his white Hyundai
a month after the killings coburger was
stopped again twice for traffic offenses
with his father on a road trip home to
Pennsylvania
hello
found out he changed the registration
plates and the car like his was seen
near the site of the murders
six weeks after the murderous police
made their move this was their raid on
his West Coast apartment kobargo was
arrested in Pennsylvania and flown back
to face the case against him it includes
a DNA match between a knife pouch left
at the murder scene and rubbish from
Burns at his family home
in Idaho its case evidence that leaves
him looking at the possibility of the
death penalty by firing squad James
Matthews Sky News Washington